[Musique]
nous travaillons sur philippe bost
d'alors c'est un peintre martinique est
qui fait d elle des animaux gigantesques
avec de la craie blanche et de ses
animaux il fait des motifs graphiques et
effet aussi des constellations les
systèmes solaires et la galaxie voici
les 15 élèves de grande section des
doublés de l'école maternelle de
pont-viau arts à fort de france
ils sont à l'origine de cette exposition
d'oeuvres inspirées de l'artiste
martiniquais philippe baudelocque c'est
l'aboutissement d'un projet scolaire
particulièrement innovant qui aura
organisé l'ensemble des enseignements de
la nuit autour de l'art les arts visuels
déforment l'apprentissage et forme
graphique ce qui a permis aux enfants de
rentrer très facilement dans l'écriture
dans ses oeuvres
il y a beaucoup de systèmes solaires de
galaxies de représentation des étoiles
donc encore intervention est en cours
enseignements nous avons en binôme
travail et le système solaire est
fabriquée système solaire donc les
enfants ont découvert l'espace et malgré
une année scolaire décousu à cause de
l'épidémie de covile et des grèves
aujourd'hui ces élèves de maternelle
lisent couramment écrivent des textes et
pour certains résolvent des problèmes
mathématiques de ce1 une aventure
extraordinaire pour cette école niché
dans un quartier à la population
multiethnique classé en zone d'éducation
prioritaire
si on m'appelle j'aime
j'ai 16 ans moi j'ai fais le signe et je
parle français et anglais je m'appelle à
la mer je suis au admis et moi j'ai fait
le colibri je parle espagnol italien
français et réelle une école qui dose de
quartier ou difficiles où on parle pas
toujours de ce quartier de manière
positive et nous avions voulu montrer
aussi bas pour viol il y a des choses
magnifiques tout se réalise
l'art est le co enseignements ont été
ici les clés de la réussite des élèves
de section des grands
poussé par le rectorat l'école
maternelle de pompière a déjà formé
plusieurs autres écoles de martinique à
cette méthode innovante